and be interested shailene woodley was  arrested on Monday for criminal  trespassing the Morgan County Sheriff's  Office confirmed to ET the 24 year old  was protesting the construction of an  oil pipeline that will run through North  and South Dakota I'm being arrested I  didn't I was down there's a lien  documented the protests live on her  Facebook  I knew a riot police are arriving riot  police arriving at this peaceful protest  where people are praying the protest  comes one day after the federal court  rejected the Standing Rock Tribes  request to halt construction on the  project  Shailene called it a peaceful protest  last month's Jailene brought a member of  the Standing Rock tribe to the New York  premiere of Snowden they're trying to  collect protect clean water not only for  indigenous communities but for all  communities around the world